it's a valuable service in a country
devastated by War on Mondays and
Thursdays the doctors offer free
consultations
Free Medical Treatments is a step
towards overcoming some of the financial
challenges people face previously many
poor people chose not to go to the
hospital because they couldn't afford it
the safe Brothers started this
initiative many years ago when they
lived in hodeidah
they offered free health checks to
families in poor neighborhoods when
fighting broke out near the coastal city
they fled leaving everything behind
when the conflict neared her data we
left for Sana that was four years ago
the experience made us even more
determined to help poor people most
public servants haven't received a
salary in seven or eight years patients
here say they are grateful this man
received treatment for knees injury
this is very helpful for people during
the harsh circumstances caused by the
war we hold projects like this can be
launched in other areas and expanded to
include more services such as surgeries
and chronic medications
more than half of Yemen's Public Health
Facilities have been partially or
completely destroyed the rest are
overwhelmed and under-resourced
the Supreme medical committee has
registered more than 60 000 patients for
Urgent Treatment abroad the health
sector has collapsed
and above clinics in Sana offers similar
Services either for free or at
discounted rates
it's a temporary solution one that
treats the symptoms but not the cause
in the past two years fewer people have
been killed in violence or fighting in
Yemen but the death toll from the
indirect impact of the war has increased
significantly and its place the burden
on the crumbling Healthcare sector
Al Jazeera sanaha
demonstrations apply